Okay, we are ready for today's meeting. We are recording and we are live.
Hi, so hello to everybody. Hope you had a wonderful week.
That everything is going well. I have some questions that I want to get to here that people sent me.
The first question is, are tiny beds okay? Is that a good thing when you are dealing with any serious disorder?
The answer to that is, everything is within reason.
So, is it the dangerous thing for your skin with the sun is burning?
It is not so much sunlight and damaging thing to your skin.
It is when you have frequent birds. That is what can damage the skin. That is what radiation does is it burns.
And that excessive heat in a bird, your epidermal layer, I am going to have to just manage everybody here.
I am going to mute all. So, if you guys have a question, please post a question on the chat so I can open it up because I was hearing too much static there.
So, tiny beds, if you are doing it mildly and you are doing it once in a while and you are doing it for the purpose of going out of vacation in a very warm, hot area, I don't want to burn.
So, it is better to tan a little bit before I get to that point. I don't see any major harm for it.
If you are addicted to tanning and you are getting tiny beds for looks all the time, then there could be problems with that.
Because even a tan is a slight burn and that does do some damage. So, sun is so good for you and it is so healthy for you.
And the sun does not cause cancer. More so, it is the sunscreens that cause cancer than the sun itself cause you cancer.
But it was in balance. So, if we are burning, then we are increasing our cancer risk because of the burn.
We had another question on the Facebook page today about dizziness and vertigo. So, I want to address that as well.
I stated that there are multiple causes of vertigo. You can look at that on the Facebook page.
The common cause of vertigo is what is called ear rocks or otoliths. You have little calcium crystals that form in the middle ear and they can break off.
That is called an otolith. And it can go into one of the semi-circular canals.
Your semi-circular canals, you have three going in different directions at each ear.
And in those canals, you have these little tea hair-like cells called silia. And you have a viscous fluid.
And as you turn your head, that viscous fluid moves and it stimulates those silia, which are connected to a nerve, and it tells your braid.
It communicates to the temporal, but tells your braid where you are in space, where your head is in space.
If you get a little otolith that breaks off, it goes into one of those canals. Now, that thing is rolling in the canal.
And you move your head, that thing starts rolling, and the viscous fluid stops when you stop moving your head.
But the little otolith continues to roll, and it's stimulating the silia, and it's telling your braid that your head, that you are still moving, what in fact you are not moving.
And that is what vertigo is. There are other causes of vertigo, but that is a major cause of vertigo.
So, some people are more prone to have these little things break off, these little otoliths. Some people will go their whole life and never have this happen.
But there's a small percentage of people that have this happen more commonly. I think the genetic piece to that is they're 10 to 4 more ox, absorb more oxilates.
And that's that's a tie to that. But how do you treat that? There is a maneuver called Eplease maneuver that you could Google EPE, EPL EYS.
And you could do Eplease maneuver. Some people will have instant relief doing Eplease maneuver.
The problem with doing an Eplease maneuver with otoliths is you need to know which semi-circular canal has the otolith, because symptom wise it will give you all the same symptoms.
So, there is a hint to whether otoliths are a cause of your dizziness. One of the hints that I ask patients are, is, okay, are you dizzy all the time? Well, no, not all the time.
Are you dizzy when you when you roll over and bed, does the world start spitting? Yes, that's a sign that it's probably an otolith.
When you sit still and you're just fine, you're not moving, do you, do you, are you spitting? No. Now turn your head to the left or right. Are you spitting? Oh, boy, though, I feel like I'm spitting.
If you have vertigo upon motion and then so think of that, that little otolith rolling around in that semi-circular canal.
And then when you stop moving after 30 seconds or so, the spitting starts to go down. Okay, now, okay, now it's not spitting anymore.
Then it's an otolith. So, which semi-circular canal is it in? And in which ear? So, Aplacement Over is performed differently depending on which semi-circular canal that it goes in.
So, if it goes the Aplacement Over that's showed on the videos that you'll see is, is well, you'll either have to do it on the right or the left.
And there's no harm in doing it on the opposite side. It's just that when you feel like you're going to throw up and you're moving your head, it's not very comfortable.
So, there is a way for a functional neurologist to tell which which canal it's in by looking at what's called the stagmus in your eye when you move to a certain spot.
But that goes beyond this conversation. So, you might have to do Aplies on the right or you might have to do it on the left.
It could also go in the lateral canal that it is, Aplies is not going to do it. You have to do what's called a barrel roll.
So, literally you lay on the floor and you roll over, you're laying with your legs out stretched on your back and you literally roll over.
Maybe you'll have to have somebody help you roll over, keep your neck straight and you roll over like a log at the log roll.
And you're rolling over like a log very slowly all the way over, all the way over, all the way over, greater than 60 degrees.
And you might be able to Google that on YouTube and see a video of that too.
If that's a less common canal for the own list to go in, but it can happen.
So, if you're not having luck removing dizziness through doing Aplies, you might want to go to many times the physical therapist knows how to do Aplies.
Many times the chiropractic functional neurologist will always know how to do it.
So, they could do it in the office so they could check what canal it's in.
So, that might help you in getting rid of that. There's other causes of dizziness and vertigo that has to do with the cerebellum.
That's the back part of the brain that controls balance.
So, if I have damage to the back part of the brain, post-concussive syndrome is a very common cause of that.
Also, food sensitivity or changes in blood sugar can affect the cerebellum very strongly because the cerebellum gets the first blood supply from the gut.
So, if I'm eating something that's causing inflammation and it's a food board, they then it can affect my cerebellum quite quickly.
Also, many medications drugs can affect the cerebellum because once you absorb that drug, it's gonna go to the cerebellum first.
And it could affect the cerebellum because dizziness and nausea and such. That's why some drugs do that.
So, those are some things that you want to explore. Never forget that if you're out of medication, your symptom, whatever symptom it is, can be the side effect of the medication.
I just told my staff that today, but it struggles with what I do over all the years is half the time I feel like I'm chasing the symptoms from the side effect of a medication that a patient is on.
And they get mad at me because I can't make their symptoms go away and the symptoms are caused from a side effect of a medication.
So, don't ignore that if you are on a medication, make sure you Google side effects of that medication and see if whatever symptom that you're dealing with, long beyond dizziness or vertigo, might be as a side effect of that medication.
So, don't ignore that piece as well.
I'm feeling I'm missing some questions that people had, but if you have any questions, type in with a chat box so that I know to unmute you.
All right. So, this I wanted to talk about, why didn't I have a slide up? Oh, because in a video that I posted with some research I was doing last night and early this morning was on super oxide dispute case and what proxy nitrate does to a cancer and what super oxide does to cancer.
I posted that on our Facebook page, so if you have a chance to watch that, there's some, I think there's some benefit to that.
Super oxide is a free radical. So, this picture here, this is another slide that from a presentation that I give a heart disease, but super oxide is a free radical that's generated in your body normally.
It is supposed to be gotten rid of by the super oxide dispute case made through the super oxide dispute case genes. So, if a person has defects on their SOD genes, they don't make a lot of SOD and therefore the hair at risk of excess super oxide.
Now, there's another gene that we look at to the NOS genes, the NOS genes, if I have defects on those genes, I'll have what's called uncoupled nitric oxide. That's not what we want to have.
Our nitric oxide needs to be coupled. If we have defects on that gene, we could have an excess of uncoupled nitric oxide.
So, that could combine together. Super oxide combines with nitric oxide that's uncoupled. It makes peroxidite trait.
Peroxidite trait is the real damageer. In that video, I talked about the damage effects of super oxide with cancer patients because super oxide in the cell blocks the apoptotic pathway, which is horrible.
Okay, that itself is horrible. So, when you have apoptosis that's blocked, well, you can't kill cancer cells and that can be the cause of cancer.
So, that's bad enough. It gets worse. It combines with nitric oxide that's uncoupled, makes peroxidite trait, which does all sorts of things, causes vasoconstriction, hypertension, a decrease endothelial nitric oxide,
and causes oxidized LDL. So, this is where more arterial problems. So, oxidized low density lipo proteins, oxidized proteins, oxidized lipids, oxidized DNA, cause just all sorts of problems.
This is obviously a cancer issue here, too, and blocks the, the H4B, which is tetrahydrobiotrid, from converting to bihydrobiotrid, which effectively changes your brain, because that is how you end up producing all your neurotransmitters.
So, can affect mood, can affect behavioral disorders, everything. So, looking at these pathways, this is just trying to, you know, not to dirt out on this stuff too much, but the reason why we want to look at these pathways and keep you healthy.
So, of course, we're dealing with cancer patients, and we just want our cancer to go away. Well, in that case, that's why we use different antioxidants, and that's why we look at the SOD genes to support those, to get the superoxide out of the body, but it goes even beyond that, because it affects all our blood vessels.
You decrease nitric oxide, etothelial nitric oxide causes erectile dysfunction, blood vessel rigidity, your blood vessels cannot expand and damage to etothelial tissue and heart problems.
So, it's an important piece to look at, right?
So, I just wanted to touch on that and just expand on what that video was about, because I think that stuff is cool.
Let's try to remember the other questions that people had. I am going to close our video right now, unless somebody else has an updated question, because I'm going to close the video and I'm going to look up these other questions.
Anybody on the line have any questions at all? Yes, though. Okay, so I get a stop by screen share, and I'm going to we're still videotaping, but I want to pull up. I know I had a question for a Zoom call question here.
So, hold with me one second.
Oh, it was on cannabis oil.
So, let's talk about that a little bit. Of course, there's not a screen share, but you could hear me.
cannabis oil. So, remember, there's in the state of Minnesota, I can't we can't sell THC oil, but we can sell the CBD oil. That's legal in all states right now.
So, I tell people there's three ways to use marijuana medicinally.
So, medicinal marijuana tends to be a hot topic with some people, especially if you grew up obeying the law, it tends to be a hot topic, which I always tell people remember that marijuana is an herb that God created.
So, use correctly, it could be beneficial, used incorrectly, it could be harmful to us. So, if you remember that, it's important. There's three different uses for marijuana, really.
So, there is, there is just smoking marijuana or taking it in a heated form, like baking it in a baked good and taking it that way.
The benefit of that in medicinal use is that it could decrease pain.
So, would it be better to be using an herb like marijuana for pain or would it be better to use an opiate for pain? Well, I think it'd be better to use an herb like marijuana for pain.
Some people don't like the side effects because it can give them a little bit of a high depending on what you're using.
We're not talking about rolling a joint and smoking a joint in marijuana. We're talking about you, if you're going to smoke it, smoke just, I've had patients literally do what are two puffs once or twice or three times a day and it eliminates all their pain meds.
And they don't get quite the high feeling. Now, I can't speak from experience because I've never smoked marijuana. So, I can't give you experience with that, but we have lots of patients who have done that for that purpose and I can speak from their experience.
So, there's benefits to using smoking marijuana at a pipe or something like that to help relieve pain, except smoking marijuana is not going to kill cancer cells.
So, the purpose of doing that is solely for pain relief. There's two components of the marijuana. There's the CBD and there's the THC.
So, the second use of marijuana is the THC. So, the THC is what you would get by smoking, but you're getting a concentrated heated form and that's what gives you the high or the hallucinogenic effect of the marijuana.
So, that's what some people like recreationally. I don't take long-term, it's great for your brain, especially if you smoke a lot, but it could have the effect to decrease pain.
So, you could, if you're going to use marijuana to kill cancer cells, because it can be an effective cancer killer, there is actually a lot of data on that.
However, just like any cancer killer, protocell mushrooms, leotron, et cetera, it is not going to work for everybody. So, don't believe what you read on Facebook or anything else.
That is the, that it's going to cure everybody's cancer, because it doesn't, there isn't anything that cures everybody's cancer.
However, it's worth the try if we've tried everything else and nothing else is working, but you have to use a very concentrated THC.
So, that is typically called Rick Simpson's oil. So, you could Google Rick Simpson's oil and learn about who Rick Simpson is. I'm not going to talk about that now, but he distills down the THC to it till it's like a paste, a black paste, almost like a resin.
And it comes in a syringe when you buy it, or you produce it, you typically put it in a syringe, and you syringe out the size of a grain of rice, and then that's the dosage, that's how Rick Simpson dosed it.
Start with a greater rice a day, go to a greater rice twice a day, three times a day, and you get up to his full dose of three grains of rice three times a day.
Now, the pros of that is that it's very concentrated THC and it can kill cancer cells. The cons of that is that it could make you really feel weird.
Not so much a pleasurable high that I'm told, but just feel it kind of wiped, which brings back to some other beneficial side effects of smoking the marijuana.
Well, it helps to relieve pain, but it also helps induce sleep, which most cancer patients need. It helps increase appetite, which most cancer patients need.
It helps decrease nausea, which is really super beneficial of most cancer patients. So it has a bunch of really beneficial effects to it.
Now, the high THC slash Rick Simpson's oil can have some of those same effects, but it can kind of knock you out a little bit, make you feel really groggy, and I've had a lot of patients say, I don't like this way, this makes me feel, well, there's other ways to dose it.
I've had people put it in capsules and do it rectally before they go to bed. I've had people put in capsules and swallow it before they go to bed. So they don't get the same harshness of the side effects of it.
And, you know, I've had patients come to me that are already taking that and I've had patients that have sought out sources to find that and get that. I don't have, I don't have access to that. It's not legal for me to have that. I'm just giving you the information.
Now, CBD oil is legal for me to have it to dispense and for you to buy anywhere, but CBD oil isn't really a core, core cancer killer.
Even though there's more and more research coming out that CBD can't have an effect on cancer, I don't know that that's really the component that's doing it or not. CBD really shines with calming the brain. It could decrease anxiety.
I think it has going to have we're going to see some research that decreases glutamate levels so that that's the back door effect that it has on cancer.
And it could help with seizures patients with seizures. It could help decrease inflammation in the brain. So that I've had some people say that it has helped their pain.
So there's just a lot more research that needs to be coming out on CBD and THC. That's really exciting. It's not going to be a cure all for everything by any stretch of the imagination, but it's really a shame that that it's not legal everywhere either.
So if you want more information on that CBD or THC contact me, we have pointed people to a pharmacy in Colorado that they've had good success getting supplies at and you don't have to be a citizen of Colorado to get it.
If you've had people just drive out there, you can get about a month supply of THC oil, the Rick Simpson oil product per day that you're there. So they stayed over and I've got two months at a time and drove back home.
I do know that like in Minnesota, our governor has said no one with cancer will ever be prosecuted for using marijuana for medicinal purposes.
And most governors, most states are in the same boat. They're never going to prosecute somebody for medicinal use of something.
If they're taking care, you see it responsibly. So I don't think there's really an issue with legality so much with that.
That sometimes people have to get over that fact of that it is, you know, has been a voodoo illegal substance for so long.
So any other questions that you want to address about that already, but experience with that that they want to share with any sort of marijuana use.
Yes.
This is Christina.
Hello, Christina.
I have been using the Rick Simpson oil for about nine months.
And my husband can go into depth on to what it helps me with.
So we use it quite a bit for her nausea when that pops up and she's not hungry. We're able to at that time use the the smokeable marijuana to more remedy that rather quickly and then more of a chronic pain issue that Chris has had in her abdomen since her surgery.
And at times that's quite debilitating, but we're able to use the cannabis oil and we dose that throughout the day.
We diluted in some coconut oil, which helps it absorb a little bit better without her having any burning or effects from the from the Rick Simpson oil, but it seems to be an absolute game changer for us at times when the appetite falls off and the pain levels also prohibit that.
It is something that she was not open to previous to her cancer diagnosis, but it has definitely been a game changer and she has changed her opinion on it 180 degrees.
And what did I tell you is the size that she's taken too much.
Hi, Dick, what are they?
Yeah, what did I wear to my first visit?
You did. You just have to give her that I just love.
So wonderful, wonderful, fantastic.
So he brought up on a point there that should be reiterated a little bit.
So like many times with many herbs, there are water soluble.
So if they they could give you a spike and then they can drop off really quickly.
If you take it with a fat, a coconut oil or butter or something like that, or you could make what's called a butter out of coconut oil and olive oil and some other oils.
You will probably affect it. You will get quite the spike, which most people think that's great.
I don't want that spike. I want a more prolonged effect.
So oil will hold it in your body longer and you'll get a greater benefit from it in the long term.
If you go to some dispensaries, you'll see that they sell a lot of the gummies and the gummies are, of course, in a sugar base.
And people like to buy them because they get this THC spike, but it's gone pretty quickly.
If you had a patient that said somebody had said her some free gummies, well, you could just take a table spoon of coconut oil before you eat one of the gummies.
You'll get a similar effect of prolonging that in your system a little bit better.
You'll get a better effect from it.
Thank you.
Any other comments about anything else other than whatever you guys want to speak about?
Nothing. All right. So if you did hear the first part where you're talking about Eplea's been over and, and dizzyed us, listen to this again, listen to the recording again.
And if anybody has any specific, remember, if you have specific questions about that really pertain to you about something we touch on in this call or something maybe you don't want to talk about in a call.
Make sure you call it just set up a time I could talk with you too. So I'm always here for you.
All right, we will add this call then.
And we will see you talk to you guys again very soon.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
All right, bye bye.
Bye.